Why should we have all the fun
when it comes to dressing up?
Well there's one person here today
who really deserves the star treatment.
And she is not only a nurse who's
been on front lines of the pandemic,
but she's also an Air Force Veteran,
who served three deployments overseas.
Yes ma'am.
Yes
And needless to say she's incredible.
Please welcome Joni Stokes.
(audience cheering and clapping)
Joni!
She's a superhero.
A superhero.
Appreciate it, being here honestly
I really appreciate being here.
There's so many nurses that you could've chose from,
so it's an honor to be here.
I'm super excited, this is totally nothing like
anything I've been a part of.
But I'm so happy to be here.
(audience clapping)
Okay well we want to thank you for
everything that you do and everything that you are.
And we want you to join in
and we will get you the star makeover, head to toe.
(audience cheering and clapping)
I love a makeover!
Yes! I mean this is awesome, let's do it!
Well someone you guys are so familiar with,
is the very infamous and famous,
star stylist Brad Goreski.
You will recognize him
(audience cheering and clapping)
There's Brad!
Because he is the stylist to the stars,
um, Demi Moore, Jenna Dewan, oh,
Kaley Cuoco!
(Laughter)
Joining him is hairstylist to the stars
such as Beyonce, you know?
Beyonce, Shakira and another red carpet maven,
Kerry Washington.
Yes Indeed!
It's Kim Kimble!
(Audience cheering and clapping)
Brad, you're dressing Kaley.
(Laughter)
Let's just say it's gonna be really, really good,
I'm really excited about this one,
it's something we've never done before.
I am one of her biggest fans, I root for her so hard,
and I can not wait to see her celebrated on this evening.
Um, Kim are you seeing any trends in particular,
that you either want to see or predict will be
on the red carpet this year?
Yes, I want to see more glamor in the hair,
not just, you know, simple,
I want to see a little bit more style,
bring some more like, Hollywood glamor into it.
So Joni, you're going to head over to Brad and Kim,
and we're going to see you at the end of the show
Thank you!
Good luck
(Applause)
Bye Joni, have fun, have fun, have fun.
Welcome back! It's finally time for our head-to-toe,
make-over reveal, throughout the hour,
Brad Goreski and Kim Kimble, two of the best in Hollywood,
have been giving our guest Joni Stokes,
an incredible nurse and veteran,
the A-List team treatment.
Brad and Kim, how do you feel about this?
Well I'm excited because she definitely
has been Kimble-ized.
(Laughter)
Brad?
She is such an unbelievable human,
we just enhanced her beauty already, she is so fabulous.
Can we see her now, can we see her now, I wanna see her?
Okay, okay, we're all surprised, none of us have seen her,
this is an authentic reveal, okay here it is,
Joni before,
All right.
So cute.
And here is Joni now,
(Audience cheers and claps)
(Upbeat Music)
Oh yeah!
(Applause drowns out speaking)
What's your favorite part?
My lips, to be honest.
Really?
Yeah, I love it.
I mean, wow.
Look at Drew, you okay? Are you okay? This is touching.
Thank you so much, honestly, thank you.
I am emotional because I, I think beauty for me
is a feeling, and if you feel beautiful then,
thank you Brad and Kim,
Yeah, I really do feel beautiful
For helping her feel that way, cause that's everything.
(Audience cheers and claps)
But, ya look perfect and amazing so please check out
Brad as the new resident judge on Canada's drag race,
(Audience drowns out speaking)
And, um, as a correspondent of course, on the E Network,
and Kim's celebrity series haircare line is now available
at Walmart, hello!
(Applause)
We love our Walmart, um Ross I love you.
I love you!
Best date in the world.
This was so much fun
Ehm, Kevin and Michelle, I just feel lucky.
We're family, we're not going anywhere,
you're stuck with us.
Okay, all right you guys,
You can tune in to the 73rd Emmy Awards,
this Sunday, September 19th on CBS,
and we'll see you all on Monday
as we kick off our second premier week in our show's
home town of the Big Apple!
(Audience cheers and claps)
All right, ready? One, two, three.
(Upbeat Music)